All right, reformed authory. How you
doing?
>> Yo yo yo, what's up? I just want to
contest the claim that the trinity is
true. So, um, I have an argument. I
developed an argument against the
trinity and I wanted to like hear you
guys thoughts about it. So, that's fine.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I'll just begin by
defining the terms for my argument. So,
I'll just begin by defining a part. A
part to me is just something about the
subject that is not the whole of the
subject. A whole is just a total value
of like some set. So my argument is very
simple. The son is either the whole of
the subject triune God or he's not. If
he's the whole of the subject the triune
god then that would mean the son is the
same as the father and the spirit. If
he's not the whole of the triune god
that means that he is a part of the
triune god. If he's a part of the triune
god that means partially is material. So
how what's your argument? What's your
reputation to it? Yeah, because the the
when you say the triune God, the triune
God is not a subject. That's the issue.
>> A subject is going to be referring to a
singular person.
>> Yeah, but you you don't believe there's
something there's like a you don't
believe the trinity is a subject.
>> The trinity is not just referring No, a
subject is going to be referring to a
person. The trinity is going to be
referring to the essence, three persons,
all the properties, etc.
>> Yeah. So, can we be referring to God as
the tri god?
>> You can, but I'm saying that's not
referring to the subject then. That's
referring to the entirety of again even
the essence and the person which is
distinct.
>> Okay. To the entirety of the essence and
the persons. Would you say the son is
the entirety of the essence and the
persons?
>> He's the entirety of the essence. To say
he's the entirety of the persons doesn't
even make any sense because he's
material. You can say he's materially
identical to the other person.
>> No, we take the set of the essence and
the persons. Is he ident? Is he the
whole of the set? Is he the whole of the
set or is he
>> Yeah. You saying you saying the whole
implies and literally implies
composition and we reject composition.
>> So you even saying the word whole we
>> either something's either whole or
subart with there's no third option. So
>> so a hole is going to infer parts exist
because a whole is all of the parts put
together right
>> yeah but you just when you said the
entirety of the essence person entirety
is just synonymous with whole.
Like like for example like do you think
like I'll show I can show you how you're
being inconsistent by by showing you
your own model. Right? So like for
example do you think like there's Allah
has 99 names. Is one of the names of
Allah the whole of the names of Allah or
is it the part of the names of Allah?
>> Dude that's just a two way that doesn't
>> No. I'm I'm saying I'm showing you how
you're going to be inconsistent. That's
what I was. It's not a two way. I'm just
going to show you how you're being
inconsistent. That's all I'm going to
show you.
>> Yeah. But I can even grant you
composition in my view. But it doesn't.
>> So you're granting your god your god is
made of parts. Allah's made
>> for the sake of the discussion of
discuss.
>> No, not for the sake of discussion. Not
for the sake of discussion. Is Allah
made of parts?
>> No, I don't believe that.
>> Okay, great. So I'm going to show you
how you're being incon. The point again,
the point is not okay is me saying this
isn't a problem because it's a problem
with you. My point of bringing this up
is to show you how you're being
dishonest with your definition. So I'm
going to show you that. So is one of is
one of the 99 names of Allah the whole
of Allah or is it a part of Allah? Dude,
do you know I'm doing internal critique?
I'm assuming you're
>> Yeah, I'm showing. Yeah. And I told you
we reject the term hole. Great. You're
going to do an internal critique. Okay.
Quick, bro. Just really quick. Just
really quick. So, you rejected Nick's
explanation
>> and he very clearly explained to you how
he rejects the terminology, the usage of
the terminology that you're using.
Let me finish please. Let me finish
please. And with you constantly
rejecting his explanation, he's then
saying, "Okay, I'm going to show you how
you're being inconsistent with your own
model." So, he's not a hey, you have
this you uh okay, I have a problem.
Well, you have this problem, too. It's a
I don't have this problem. I explain
that I don't have this problem, but you
still insist that I have this problem.
Let me show you that you're you have
this problem and see if you're going to
be consistent.
>> Yes. So, so his explanation isn't
satisfactory because he contradicted
himself.
>> You say that it's not satisfactory
doesn't make it doesn't make it so. If
it's not satisfactory, you should be
able to answer the question I asked.
>> Yeah. Can I elaborate why it's not
satisfactory? Because first of all, you
said the triune god's not the subject.
You said we can refer to the triune god
in so far as we picking out the entirety
of the essence and the persons. Entire
is literally synonymous with the whole.
So, you already contradict yourself when
you said there's no. So now the question
is if you take the set triune God which
consists of the father son spirit the
son is not identical to the whole set.
He's not ident.
And if you believe again this is why I
ask you you're not being consistent.
>> I'm showing you I'm showing you you're
not being consistent that you even in
your model you would not use that term
for God.
>> What's the distinction between the term
and the term? What's the answer
question? I'm trying to show is one of
the 99 names of Allah is that the whole
of Allah or is it the part of Allah?
>> It's the whole of Allah or is it the
part of Allah?
>> Yes,
>> that's the question.
>> Yeah. So, I would reject this
definition. I'm going with your
>> This is Thank you very
When you when you reject this, be quiet,
please. Nick, when you reject this
definition, he left. He ran away after
that. I didn't kick him.
>> No,
>> he just left.
>> He just left. We didn't kick him. He
just left.
>> You when when you say, "Hey, man. We
don't We don't take that definition. We
I reject that definition." It's a
problem when you do that, Nick. But it's
cool when I do it. That's crazy how that
works.
>> I can reject that. You can't do You
can't use that on me, but I can use it
on you, man. Get out of here, Mo.
>> That is crazy, boy. I knew it. I knew he
wasn't going to be consistent. I knew
it. This is what they do, bro. They say
you have to do it this way, but we
don't. Like, what?
>> Yeah. You have to use the term wholeness
and you you have to use this terminology
and you have to apply that to your God.
But when it comes to my theology, I I
don't have to. And
>> you can't use the whole part. But except
when it comes to me, then it's not.
>> I just work.
>> Nice.
>> Crazy.
>> He got out of here, too. The qu I I That
is hilarious. I'm not surprised, but I I
I kind of am thrown off. Like I can't
believe he just left like that.
>> Bro, I'm not surprised. That was
embarrassing. That's embarrassing.
>> Oh man, that's too good. That's too
good. Muslims, y'all's got to come
better, man. Come better. Be consistent.
Be honest. Be direct.
>> All right. Be honest. Be consistent. Be
direct. Please.
>> What's good?
>> What's up?
>> Uh I just want to share with y'all
what's your evidencees to prove Islam
false.
>> Sure.
>> Multiple things. That's why you want to
go about it. Muhammad says that we can
find him in the previous scriptures and
we can't. So therefore, he's a false
prophet.
>> And anything else? Cuz I could say
Isaiah. I don't remember the ex verse,
but I could say that verse Isaiah could
talk about it.
>> You can't say Isaiah cuz it's not about
Muhammad.
>> It doesn't exist. Yeah.
>> I would I could interpret it to be. So
it's pretty clear to me.
>> Show us show us show us where Muhammad
is. Isaiah,
>> you know which verse I'm talking about.
>> You the one bringing you
>> We don't believe he's anywhere. I don't
remember which number, but if y'all know
what I'm talking about, it saves us some
time.
>> Cuz we don't think he's there.
>> Okay, give me a sec to find it.
>> All right, take your time.
>> Music.
>> Hey, you said Isaiah 42, Zach?
>> Yeah. My bad. Yeah.
>> Where in Isaiah 42 do you think it talks
about Muhammad?
>> The whole chapter.
>> Oh, this going to be bad. Okay, let's go
to
>> Well, until Yeah.
>> You sure?
>> Until 17.
>> All right. So, let's start off. It says,
it's right here on the screen. It says,
"Blessed behold my servant whom I
uphold, my chosen in whom my soul
delights. I have put my spirit upon him.
He will bring forth justice to the
nations." All right, let's start with
verse one. Can you show me a verse where
it says that the uh spirit of Allah was
put on Muhammad.
>> Sorry. It says God says that I have put
my spirit upon him. Do you believe that
Allah has a spirit?
>> I believe that's referring to angel
Gabriel.
>> Doesn't say that.
>> Doesn't matter.
interpretations are taken. Not
everything is little. You know that.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't care about how you
interpret. I interpret. I care about
what the text says. Does the text says
that I put my angel on him or my spirit?
>> Spirit.
>> Okay. Good. Can you show me where do
Like I said again, do you believe that
Allah's Allah has a spirit?
>> I believe he has Gabriel. Yes. And is
referred to as in multiple places.
>> Does he have a spirit?
>> No.
>> So Allah doesn't have a spirit. So
therefore, this can't be about Muhammad
because this says God put his spirit
upon the servant. So
>> I'm not going to lie.
>> Say that again.
>> I think that's stupid to not allow the
spirit to mean Gabriel.
>> Well, okay. How about this? If you can
show me one reference that says that
Gabriel is the spirit, then you got me.
I'll allow
>> the spirit of God.
>> Well, in the Bible, I don't know.
>> Well, in the Bible, it doesn't exist.
Um, the spirit of God is is co-creator
and sustainer of the universe, sharing
the very essence of God. So, can't be an
angel. But you're saying Gabriel is the
spirit. Maybe you can use your Quran.
Show me in the Quran where Gabriel is
the spirit. And I'll I I'll let you have
verse one at least or at least step one
of verse one. You there?
>> Yeah. I'm sorry. I'm going just find it
real quick.
>> Can you read it for us?
>> Sure. And then
>> Huh?
>> I don't know. It cut out. Yeah, we can't
hear you, bro. Zach, you got to come off
mute, man. What's going on?
>> My bad. Y'all hear me now? So, what does
the verse say?
>> Oh, when I go to read it, you can't hear
me, so I can't read it.
>> Okay, I got you. 1785
>> says, "They ask you, oh prophet, about
the spirit. Say, its nature is known
only to my Lord, and you, oh humanity,
have been given but little knowledge."
>> So, Zach, does it say that Gabriel's the
spirit?
>> I lie, that actually goes against your
claim, bro.
>> It go me.
>> Yes. They have to stage
the they said it's nature's only known
to my lord. So then that means Muhammad
don't know what the spirit is. It can't
be angel angel Jabrel because he he knew
Angel Jabel.
>> These dudes man this is what happens
when you guys become Muslim. I'll let
you know right now. When you become a
Muslim
>> your brain gets fried.
>> Your brain gets fried. It's an
alabottomy. As as somebody once said
here in this chat, it's an alabottomy.
All right. Your brain gets severed.
>> All right. shattered, shredded, and this
is what you become. So, we're warning
you now. If you are thinking about
becoming a Muslim and saying your
shahada and having an alabottomy
performed on you,
>> we're now
>> this is what it's going to look like.
Tid, how you doing?
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Yep.
>> So, I am fine. How about you?
>> Pretty good. Do you believe in the
crucifixion of Jesus?
>> No. Why not?
>> I also
>> What?
>> Why not?
>> Because I am a Muslim, you know. But
that's no reason to reject an obvious
and objective truth and objective
>> just because you're a Muslim.
>> You should probably stop being a Muslim
and and accept the facts.
>> Yes, but I cannot believe in Trinity.
>> That's fine. What about the crucifixion?
Can you believe in the crucifixion?
>> Yes, I can believe that. But since I am
a Muslim for other reasons, I cannot
believe. So basically, you're saying
that you have no objective reason in
reality to reject the crucifixion of
Jesus. You only object you only reject
the crucifixion because you're a Muslim
and it goes against your your said
beliefs as as a Muslim. Is that right?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So basically all the objective evidence
and facts point to Jesus actually being
crucified historically, but just Islam
goes against that and so that's why you
reject it. Well, actually Islam accepts
that people uh we will we believe in
crucifixion because it it was made
appear so right.
>> So Islam accepts the fact that people
believe that Jesus was crucified but
just not that he was crucified.
>> Yes.
>> Exactly.
>> And why?
>> So it is in line.
>> Why do why do people why do people
believe Jesus was crucified?
>> So they saw that way.
>> How?
Well, there are some stories like
someone made appear like Jesus.
>> Who who did that?
>> Who was that? Someone.
>> Well, it's just a story, you know. It is
not in Quran or hadith in experience.
>> So, what So, what's what's the actual
what happened? Why why did people see
because you said it's what they saw. So,
how did people see Jesus uh crucified?
How did that happen? If if he wasn't
crucified,
>> well, I don't know for sure.
>> So, how do you know that that's what
people saw? Or let me ask it this way.
How do you know that what people saw
wasn't actually the case that he
actually was crucified? How do you know
that it actually wasn't how they saw it?
>> I cannot know for sure for because it is
not in a historical uh tablet, you know,
but since I am a Muslim for other
reasons, I accept Islam. I also I must
also accept this. But it look it seems
like the Quran or Islam got this wrong,
right? If we're looking at the objective
evidence and the historical evidence, it
looks like Islam got this wrong. Why do
you still hold on to it if it got this
wrong?
>> Well, I think the explanation
uh seems in line with what you call with
facts.
>> Okay. What is what's the explanation
then?
>> The explanation before you couldn't tell
me. Well, people saw that way and that's
what history says, right?
>> History says that Jesus actually was
crucified, not that it was an illusion.
You're saying that it was an illusion.
>> History cannot say it it was an
illusion. It just says it just shows
what we have.
>> Yeah. It shows what we have in in act in
actuality. In reality, not in an
illusion. It says in reality Jesus was
crucified in the first century under
Lord, please.
>> It was an illusion. Yes.
>> Right. So the Quran comes and says that
it's an illusion not in reality. So it
doesn't match
>> reality, right?
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> So the Quran is going against objective
evidence and reality by saying that it
didn't actually happen and that it was
just an illusion.
>> So the Islam you okay?
>> Yes. Yes, we can say that.
>> You want me to pray for you?
>> What?
>> No, I don't need.
>> You do? You're coughing. You sound
terrible. My God heals.
>> Amen.
>> There was a Muslim coughing before on
the on the stream and I prayed that uh
that God touches his lungs. He was
coughing really badly and then he was
able to have a flowing conversation ever
since. That's just the power of
>> Okay, you can pray. Let's see uh whether
it works.
>> Let's see if it works. Lord, touch him.
Lord, touch his heart. Touch his lungs
and uh heal him. Help him with this
cough, Lord.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> In Jesus name. You got to say in Jesus
name with me.
>> Okay. Besides crucifixion, can we go
back to the previous conversations
because I listened to you and n
>> fiction? You haven't explained what
happened.
>> I see it was an illusion and it is just
an interpretation and it is not uh in in
contradiction with historical facts.
>> All right, let's let's do this one more
time. When it comes to historical facts,
does does history say it was an illusion
or that it happened in reality?
>> History cannot say whether it was an
illusion or it was a reality. It just
shows the data and you say that the we
>> notice he stopped coughing by the way.